[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here client all right whatever
whatever wow whatever so are you like a
cow or a Dalmatian I am the the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
that's why
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
wanna get out of here oh when
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy danger this is
unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea
what's a guy gotta do to join this
spider team you never be part of this
don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99
he had a terrible
grenade you have a baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
to send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
can't stop me now you can't run forever
dude I can't lose one more friend
he's telling me how my story is supposed
to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
and then I looked at my oh cool let me
guess he died
[Music]